[Music]
show opens up on earth getting head
hey golf is easy now and yet despite the
surrounding explosions and cataclysm
still unspeakably boring wearing
sunglasses indoors
also why does rick put his sunglasses on
in the living room only to take them off
before he and morty have even made it
outside a place where the sunglasses may
actually be needed
with this show i could totally buy that
they took a detour via some far away
planet with 42 suns on their way from
the living room to the garage but if
that's the case why didn't rick give
morty a pair as well
it's not god summer she's allowed to
think it's god if she wants honey
mixing parenting and politics i mean
religion i mean religion in politics i
mean this is how you get ants summer
hi i'm morty's math teacher i'm also
part of the street team inviting folks
to the church downtown so we can pray
together how long ago did mr potato head
in space
turn up have they really had time to
organize a street team dedicated to
inviting people to church
if so where are your priorities people
if you can mobilize this quickly why not
help the probable millions that have
been displaced by aforementioned natural
disasters
also why is the math teacher not
questioning the fact that rick morty
just flew away in a
spaceship right in front of him how is
praying going to help
beth would be schwifty at tv sins seti
norad and every broadcaster on the
planet are attempting to show this being
what humanity's got
string theory world history the human
genome have you tried sending in launch
codes
what that's a terrible idea is general
warmonger suggesting they send nuclear
launch codes to an
obviously superior alien being with
clearly questionable intent
now i'm sure his actual meaning here was
to fire the missiles but that is not
what he said people
mr president what america's got is 70
000 megatons of kaboom boom
i wanted to send the fact that 70
thousand megatons must be a colossal
over exaggeration of how many nuclear
weapons america has
after a small amount of googling it
turns out that is the generally accepted
estimate of the size of our nuclear
arsenal
and that is a sin
now the sunglasses are back so why did
they take rick's spaceship in the first
place why not just portal gun their way
in like they were clearly going to do in
the first draft of this script
also this begs the question why does
rick have a spaceship at all surely it's
easier safer and quicker to just portal
gun everywhere
stay back this watch turns people into
snakes we will find out later rick has
actually murdered these people and the
snakes are being released from a
contraption to sell the illusion and he
is not punished for it then or now
so the sin as always is kids i mean
murder
i mean give me a ding pharrell newman
corgan and that dream guy
they're all dead the grammy sir there
was an earthquake and all the musicians
all the famous ones they're gone when
was the last time randy
newman was it the grammys or billy
corrigan for that matter
get this man and his grandson on a black
hawk to area 51
or and this could be a terrible
inconvenience for everyone i understand
use the portal you double down and
always hit on a soft 16.
i think hitting on soft 16s has landed
the church in plenty enough hot water as
it is thank you very much
in case you confused it with nevada
desert the setting of that awful dave
bautista zombie movie
yes i'm gonna send army of the dead at
every and any opportunity regardless of
the size of the shoehorn required
get schwifty what the hell is that it's
our world's best effort that's what
how can that possibly be true okay every
artist at the grammys was killed but
there are plenty of great artists that
have never been nominated for a grammy
what about the kinks the strokes the
spice girls
the talking heads the planet's about to
be destroyed by a literal talking head
your saviors are right there
i like what you got good job
this song works mr president
you're gonna want to see this you'd
better come take a look at this cliche
sure he started picking up on a garbled
signal we're decrypting it now
decrypting it based on what frick wasn't
here you wouldn't even know what these
aliens were called let alone their
language
24 hours five planets
five songs but in the end there can only
be one
planet music trashy reality tv set in
space
this show sounds incredible i can't wait
to binge all 988 seasons
uh it's probably a bad time to mention
it but any astronauts you guys had in
orbit are definitely dead
everyone on earth except orbiting
astronauts survives this
earlier all marty had to do is press the
key and the keyboard automatically
played a funky beat wouldn't this time
be better spent cycling through the
pre-programmed beats instead of trying
to accidentally himself into a tune
also while we're on the topic of the
keyboard shouldn't they find the person
that programmed the keyboard with the
winning beat i'm fairly certain they
weren't invited to the grammys
you can put your faith in nukes if we
get through this general until then
i'll put mine in rick and morty usually
i would also be in favor of anything
other than the nuclear option but
after having sent a good few of these
episodes the phrase i put my faith in
rick and morty makes me lean towards the
big red button as a safer option with
the opportunity
for far less damaging fallout we should
pack up and leave town
now and go where is it not clear by the
floating heads in the sky that there's
nowhere to just pack up and head to
we hereby send these unwantable skyward
that they might be inhaled by the
many heads this is an entirely
inefficient method of dealing with your
unwantables do you know how many helium
balloons it takes to lift your average
person the internet does
it would take approximately 65 000
liters of helium or 60 000 liters of
hydrogen to lift your average sized
human that's over 5 000 regular sized
balloons
also you'd probably need to double that
if you wanted to get any sort of
altitude for smiting
movie talker hey wait no that's probably
fair
please help me you can reach me if you
try please help me inappropriate
joke teller okay now i just feel
attacked morty
bird person morty lands on a planet of
bird people and just happens to be
greeted by the one bird person he knows
what the f you can turn into ice my
story begins at the dawn of time in the
far away realm of alpha betrium
23 minute tv show has time for this
amount of ice position
okay things are getting out of hand
getting giant head from space has
created cataclysmic natural disasters
around the world
the planet has been teleported to who
the fork knows where to participate in
some sort of intergalactic singing
contest with an 80
mortality rate and all of your best
musicians are already dead i repeat
getting out of hand i'm setting the
nuclear option to launch one minute into
earth's performance
and you mr president i hope you like
being hit in the face with a gun
wait wait wait why doesn't the general
need the president to be conscious so
that he can authorize said nuclear
option if he doesn't need the
president's codes or authorization why
hasn't he launched them already
i believe i can access the history of
rick's gun and help you get back to him
snooping through the browser history of
someone else's electronic device not
that you'd find anything in mind
nope no sir not mine clean as a whistle
[Music]
and you guys did you guys see that one
thing on the did you see it at the place
the one thing
can we can we move on now once in for
the mental image resulting from reading
the band name
flesh curtains i married you because
you're the love of my life
going to need a whole lot of balloons
full of an intergalactic skip
just launch the missiles maybe all it
takes to launch nuclear missiles is one
guy at a computer pressing a button but
if that's true
i don't want to know about it and it's
no less of a sin after 988 seasons of
planet music
the cromulons have decided to declare
earth the final winner
and bring our musical reality show to a
conclusion
goodbye oh man now what am i gonna watch
ooh
maybe there's a uk version trade secret
mr president particle beam in a
wristwatch
snake holster on the leg but how does he
refill the snakes while he's out and
about
[Laughter]
laughing at murder
you think water's fast you should see
ice
space a final frontier a giant head has
entered earth's gravity
triggering climate change and natural
disasters we thought were impossible
for at least another eight years look at
the size of that boy's head
time to go morty uh where the pentagon
[Applause]
you can't fight in here this is the war
room you're gonna want to put them on
that giant speaker system at your sonic
testing facility at area 51.
i guess you'd like to see the big tamale
huh when god deals you in eleven you
don't fold and you always double down on
the
left
and what's your plan general we still
have the nuclear option on my word we
can launch a missile at
every one of those heads in the sky hey
you better find yourself someplace to
hide and keep praying nobody ever finds
you
now you're thinking with portals
in this universe there's only one
absolute
everything freezes iced tea
it's with these people man lemonade read
the sign
lemonade